morning
so this is our fifth annual conference
which intends to explore the future
energy mix
uh over the next 15 years
given current trajectories in 15 years
atmospheric co2 levels will be probably
over
450 parts per million
the last time we saw that was between 5
and 10 million years ago
there was no ice on greenland
if we
continue to procrastinate
by the end of the century co2 levels
will be at a minimum of 750 parts per
million
last time we saw something like that was
35 to 45 million years ago
there was no ice on
antarctica co2 exerts a strong control
on climate
and we probably won't lose all that ice
in the coming century but
that kind of co2 levels will have
dramatic effects on regional climate
on the water cycle on disease
stability of ice sheets
and sea level rise it's almost a promise
and that's fine in fact we don't need to
worry about it as long as you're not
concerned about people
and and the impact of on culture
okay
now you know when i invoke this
perspective
it
some people think it's demoralizing but
it's really not intended to be that way
this sort of information should energize
people
to take a hard look at the future of
energy because really energy is climate
and our energy use and the type of
energy we decide to invest in today will
determine the state of earth's climate
tomorrow
today's fossil fuel
uh
fossil fuels provide about 90 percent of
the world's energy and that's the cause
for the rise in atmospheric co2
conventional projections
uh still show about 75 percent of the
world's energy
driven by fossil fuel in the year 2030
and 50 years 15 years from now
but you know we've all told our parents
or at least i certainly have that
conventional wisdom isn't necessarily
always correct
and
things could change fast with
innovations and technology and and new
regulatory frameworks
it's quite possible
with uh what's called disruptive energy
technologies like solar power or wind
and and perhaps more mature conventional
type energies like
nuclear energy which is
an important mix and including new
energies like fusion
uh that
these kind of systems can be integrated
into the world uh power systems much
further than predicted
okay so
where do we look
towards for conventional wisdom
for 40 years the large international
company oil company royal dutch shell
has committed a significant amount of
resources
to forecasting the future of energy and
they do this by presenting and
evaluating multiple
alternative energy scenarios as if each
one has an equal chance
of of occurring
as time unfolds
their work is particularly interesting
this week given that the
ipcc the intergovernmental panel on
climate change has released its first
report on how to mitigate
climate change okay so
our first speaker this morning we'll
we'll begin with neil golightly of the
royal dutch shell will present
the shell energy scenarios
and this will be followed by two panel
discussions with distinguished experts
from around the world who who will speak
about topics related to the present
state of energy and the future of world
energy
and near the end of the conference we'll
we'll hear from karen sito
she's a professor of geography here at
the school of forestry and environmental
sciences
on her uh
new
ipcc chapter on human settlement
urbanization and its effect on world
energy and global climate
and finally we'll conclude with
uh
a presentation by nobel laureate and
chairman of the ipcc as well as the
founding
director of the yale climate energy
institute dr pituri
with a perspective on energy
and climate impacts
so
our first speaker neil golightly
is a vice vice president of america's
communication of shell oil company in
houston he was previously based in
london where he led communications and
stakeholder engagement for shells
downstream businesses including
alternative energies
before joining shell in 2006 he led
sustainable business strategies for ford
motor company where he worked closely
with the organization sustainability
to produce auto industries first report
on business implications of climate
change
his career has spanned a wide range of
roles from sustainable development and
corporate communications
to chief of staff for the chairman of
ford to pentagon speech writing
to u.s naval aviator
please welcome our first speaker neil go
lightly
and you're off great
thank you very much that's uh it's
really a very great uh pleasure to be
here uh mike at some point i want to
understand a little bit more about your
relationship with fire but we'll we'll
come back to that um a bit later on um
mark really uh framed the the challenge
extremely well it's a challenge that
shell recognizes it's a challenge that
uh that shell
worries about on almost a a daily basis
so it's uh it's an extraordinary
privilege to be here to be able to share
um some perspectives and and also to
perhaps hear what's on your mind and to
take a few things back home
with me uh yale the yale name obviously
carries a an enormous amount of
intellectual mystique i applaud greatly
the work that's done here at the ycei uh
and and yale broadly the the yale people
that i know think not only very deeply
about these kinds of issues and these
kinds of of challenges but my experience
is that yale people also think
very responsibly about these kinds of
challenges as well and by that i mean
not being willing to accept easy
conclusions
always being aware and conscious of the
systemic consequences of some of the
choices and some of the decisions that
could be made
and certainly
conscious as well of that sort of
consilience between the humanities and
the sciences and the technology
how people and societies and communities
work and how technology and economic
models and businesses work and that
interconnection is one that i think is
very important in the shell world we
call that the technical and the
non-technical side of our business uh so
it's it's
it's a fascinating intersection uh
thanks uh mark also for the for the
introduction it it helps uh i think uh
uh to uh in understanding where i'm
coming from to
see how i engage with some of this
material i certainly don't come at this
as an expert in science as an expert in
climate as an expert in economics even
if i thought i was an expert i wouldn't
try to admit that in in this room
certainly
i do come at it however from the point
of view of what is the role of the
corporation in some of these challenges
not only the oil and gas business and in
a corporation like ours but corporations
more broadly a lot of the work i've done
both in ford uh and in shell has been
about trying to find that mutual value
at the intersection of an institution
like mine and and the world the
community the society that uh that our
institution serves uh and uh and that's
a focus of of how i certainly engage
with uh with this material
before i go on
i have to say
we there are no predictions no future
predictions and what i'm about to talk
about but we will be talking about some
things in the future that might be
considered this is the sec's way of
saying don't make any investment
decisions based on what i'm about to say
so
why scenarios
michelle has been doing scenarios for
a little over 40 years or so and and
that scenario's work has helped with uh
our business strategists and business
decision makers to both anticipate and
deal with uh with uh
issues and developments as diverse as
the collapse of the soviet union the oil
shocks in the 1970s even the emergence
and especially perhaps the emergence of
of climate as a as a major
challenge and uh issue in the in the 90s
the scenarios are done by a small team
inside royal dutch shell led by a
gentleman named jeremy bentham some of
you have uh have met him
i think there is a certain cosmic
propinquity in the fact that jeremy
shares a name with the the storied
philosopher
and it's probably indicative of the of
the quality of work that comes out of
that that scenarios team at least we
certainly would like to
to think so
and the way the scenarios team goes
about their work is they they identify
some of the broad outlines of of issues
that the the company and business like
ours might need to meet
and then they engage with a wide number
of leading thinkers all over the world
in a wide variety of disciplines and
again some of you in this room have
actually engaged with the scenarios team
in that process so uh hopefully you'll
you'll recognize your input and uh and
sort of a brief summary i'm about to to
to give you
um by the way um i'm not going to try to
pretend this is a book tour but if uh
all of what i'm about to talk about does
come out of
this very rich publication that uh that
we put out uh last year in conjunction
with the new lens scenarios and there
are copies of it available as as you
depart
one very very important point about
scenarios they are not forecasts
it's not a prediction
uh and the difference between a scenario
and a prediction or a forecast and i'll
go ahead and just build this all the way
uh is really something like this a
forecast which is which is something
that some of our competitors actually do
very well but a forecast actually starts
with
a very singular unified model of of what
the present is all about and then it
looks at the trajectory of how that
model could unfold and it sort of sets
out a very specific prediction of where
that's going to take us at some point in
uh in the future
and that certain that device certainly
has has its purposes and it has a
certain amount of value
scenarios on the other hand are much
different scenarios start with the
realization that they're actually a
variety of different mental models of
where we are currently
and then it looks at the multiple
pathways that could evolve from those
various mental models in various
directions and some of them will
intertwine some of them will intersect
some of them will diverge
and it creates a range of possible
features that that should be considered
uh and the way i kind of think about it
in my very layman's terms it's a little
bit like vacation planning so if i pack
based on a very specific forecast of
what the weather is going to be where
i'm going there's a very good chance
that that forecast is going to be wrong
and i'm going to have the wrong clothes
in my suitcase
on the other hand if i look at a range
of scenarios as to what that weather
might be where i'm going i'm going to
have a much better chance of optimizing
the selection of clothing i put in my
suitcase and have a better chance of
having a better vacation so that's a
very simple way of
certainly the way i can understand
forecasts and and scenarios
um
certainly they're important um also in
the context of of our business the
lifetime of energy projects are
extremely long as as all of you know 30
40 50 years even and we need to have
a way of thinking about the possible
long-term consequences of short-term
decisions
and vice versa
finally i should note that these these
scenarios are
plausible scenarios necessarily
plausible they start with a certain
level of kind of boundary around what we
know that we know today
and they explicitly exclude those things
that we don't know
or that might emerge in the in the
future
so
as you'll see later on there are aspects
of these scenarios that aren't
particularly encouraging aren't
particularly optimistic but they don't
yet accommodate the possibility that
there will be some kind of discontinuous
shift either in the behavior of our
markets in the technology
in policy so do keep that in mind as we
go along it's one of the reasons by the
way that we update our scenarios on a
regular basis every three four five
years we will actually develop a new set
of scenarios that accommodate new
thinkings new thinking and new mental
models
so our new lens scenarios the the most
current version of our scenarios are are
wider ranging than many of the versions
that we've done in the past
they go well beyond um a simple look at
economic models
the supply and demand models uh the uh
the
potential uh
uh development of of policy and they
actually look across the wide spectrum
of society at cultural factors at
economic factors societal factors
political factors environmental
and
tries to make sense of that of that
entire systemic uh context in which uh
which uh the energy future plays out
um also traditionally scenarios uh and
and some of you have done a lot of work
in in scenarios traditionally scenarios
come in groups of three uh or four uh
we've actually walked away from that a
bit we've we've settled in the last
couple of times that we've done the
scenarios on on a uh on a selection of
of two and the reason for that is
what often happens is if you have a
selection of three there's kind of you
know a range over here on this side of
the spectrum and one over here on this
side of the spectrum and sort of one in
the middle and the and the tendency is
for people to sort of default to that
average or that middle and sort of call
that a a forecast and work from there so
we we've intentionally gone for for for
two scenarios the last couple of times
and our newest two are called mountains
uh and oceans uh uh it would not be a
proper scenario if it didn't have some
sort of clever name associated with it
our last ones were scrambled and
blueprints these are mountains and
oceans and you'll see in a moment why
they're called that
but
before i get into uh into the mountains
of notion specifically just a couple of
thoughts on words about the the
landscape underlying them and and first
to start with a note on pathways um and
these are are
this is a concept that gets used often
through the new lens scenarios
um and they can be applied to countries
they can be applied to businesses they
can be applied to families they can
probably even be applied to sports teams
but it really is a description of how
institutions organizations sort of work
through a period of stress
and a a period of tension
and they're really kind of two ways room
to maneuver and trapped transition or
trapped in transition
and in that room to maneuver pathway
what what uh what the scenarios team
sees is that
a country for example uh will experience
mounting stress mounting tension around
some particular issue and then there's a
sort of a period of drift as uh as as we
try to comprehend what that tension and
what that stress means what are the
options what are the risks what are the
opportunities what are the potential
solutions
and then eventually there's some early
perhaps mini crisis that that actually
catalyzes some form of action and in the
room to maneuver pathway there's enough
resilience there's enough flexibility
there's enough intellectual capacity to
actually shift to a new model that
addresses that stress or that
addresses that tension
and then the the process begins
over again until the next tension or the
nest next stress comes along a fairly
healthy uh a fairly resilient way of
dealing with uh with tensions as they
come along trapped transition on the
other hand is something much different
again mounting stress around a
particular issue tension uh be it uh
climate economy cold war whatever a
period of drift as people try to come to
grips with it
an early crisis which because there
isn't enough resilience or there isn't
enough uh
capacity or or or economic flexibility
in in the system uh results in in a
fairly paralyzed reaction or uh
inadequate uh
uh ways of addressing that uh that
tension uh which simply creates sort of
a vicious cycle of increasing levels of
stress until that mini crisis at the
front end becomes an existential crisis
at which point you either fall into
complete decay and collapse and and it's
game over or
to use a business term you kind of write
off the asset and and you reset and and
you start something completely new
um examples uh in
in
in the context of the shell scenarios
room to maneuver
china might be considered a country to
be in that kind of room to maneuver
space where they're actively working
sort of punctuated reform to to address
some of the energy challenges in the in
the case of the topic that we're
addressing today or the climate
challenges trapped in transition oh by
the way i should also mention the
cities
many cities are exhibiting some really
exciting i think innovative approaches
to uh to this room to maneuver uh
pathway a trap transition uh the eu is
probably a good example of an
institution that's trapped in transition
where they uh the can keeps getting
kicked down the road um inadequate
responses to uh to various mini-crisis
uh and those uh those crises just keep
getting bigger and bigger with the
consequence that there is a significant
erosion of political and economic
capital as the as the problems continue
to grow
it's uh probably also important to note
a couple of things one is institutions
obviously can move from from one to
another i mentioned cities earlier i was
in uh in detroit uh two weeks ago we're
announcing a big program that we're that
we're doing in detroit in 2015.
i spent a lot of years in detroit when i
was in the in the auto company
i had personally more or less written
off detroit as i think a lot of people
had as a completely lost cause uh and it
was clearly a city that was completely
trapped in in transition if not already
on its way to decay and collapse what's
extraordinary if any of you have been
there lately is just how much detroit
has been able to turn itself around yes
the the the bankruptcy is in the in the
headlines but here is a city now that it
is finding that sort of uh
reset mode uh if you will kind of moving
into now room to move or with some some
incredible uh uh city planning that's
going on uh using it as a source of
great innovation so a good example of
how an institution can move from one to
the other
um and and i think it's important also
to to think uh especially in the context
of climate and and the challenge that
mark laid out just a little bit earlier
on and that most of us think about a lot
is what are the inhibitors to breaking
out of a trapped mode
and and the gaps between the the actual
and desired state
can often produce as much fear
anxiety denial conflict
rather than the kind of courage the
innovation imagination and leadership
that's required also a lack of social
capacity institutional capacity economic
flexibility resilience can also prevent
moving out of that trapped transition
so earlier i talked about the starting
point of mental models of where we are
today and of course uh scenarios don't
start from a blank sheet of paper they
start with something that's uh that's
actually uh already happening and uh
we kind of called out six of them here
probably if we brainstorm in this room
we could come up with another 10 or 20.
uh but just briefly a few of these some
of them very self-explanatory
we're obviously in a period of
intensified economic cycles um the the
the crisis of 2007 and eight were only
the most uh prominent examples of that
uh but also the euro crisis um the uh
the propensity of uh of the u.s
government to engage in uh fiscal
brinksmanship on a regular ba basis
could could also fall into that category
political and social uh instability you
can probably spin any globe and put your
finger on it
and find yourself close to some place
where there is some level of political
and social instability in the middle
east thailand venezuela
certainly the most recent
crisis around crimea and
and the uh
and the ukraine uh as a as a former uh
cold warrior as a former naval officer
it's fascinating to see some of the
the the dynamics re-emerging in that
space
building a mini lateral world this this
may require a little bit of of of
explanation as as the traditional
institutions that that engage
across
national powers national economies uh
increasingly failed to accommodate the
rise of uh of new powers new trends of
new uh economic
powers the new relationships are
beginning to emerge those old
institutions aren't accommodating
nearly the the right level of engagement
so you see things like the g20 emerging
and other bilateral relationships the
demographic transitions and urbanization
again probably well known to most of you
in this room the increase of population
heading towards 9.5
billion people at the middle of the
century and the creation on average of a
city of a million people every week for
the next 30 years is certainly a trend
that that needs to be accommodated i
would hasten to say by the way we kind
of think of that almost automatically
many times it's sort of this dystopic
kind of challenge uh in fact
i think a lot of of uh
of innovators are looking at that as a
huge opportunity to be much more
efficient in the way that we we meet
society's needs um but it's not just the
the size of the of the population but
its population is becoming radically
younger in some cases
some populations becoming radically
older
generational educational and economic
expectations changing lifestyle
expectations changing from one
generation to the next uh and all those
uh fall into that that dynamic
challenged environmental boundaries
climate is is obviously the the most
prominent uh and yet it is uh a part of
a what uh ed shell we've we've called
the stress nexus we're not the only ones
who call it that
but it's this linkage between water
energy and food with biodiversity and
and climate being kind of the package
that it all falls into and of course
that stress nexus uh spreads across
national boundaries political boundaries
certainly across corporate boundaries in
a way that makes the collaboration and
the engagement on some of these
challenges even more important
and then all of that sort of
drives emerging resources across the
entire spectrum so
uh traditional resources whether it's
hydrocarbons in in deep water or or in
the arctic all the way through to gas
and shale gas and the revolution that
we've seen in this country all the way
through to uh the uh the the uh
emergence uh and the and the rapid
growth in solar uh wind and
at at some point
hydrogen as well
and
i have a particular interest in how the
dilemmas of energy and climate change
land with the the billions of people out
there for for whom these kinds of issues
are either
seemingly remote
or in some cases impenetrable or
in other cases seemingly insoluble uh
and and i i look at that in the context
of the two billion people or so uh in
the world who live on less than two
dollars a day have no access to any uh
energy outside of biomass whatsoever uh
there's another three uh billion or so
who live on something less than uh than
uh
uh forty dollars a day and that's maybe
enough to uh to pay for basic
electricity uh there's another billion
uh that uh that lives on less than
eighty dollars a day and that's enough
to to run a washing machine possibly and
then there's that billion uh that that
are uh have that first world lifestyle
uh perhaps best defined is the ability
to get on an airplane and fly someplace
for
a holiday
and certainly different societies have
very very different needs and very
different priorities which of course
raises the urgent question
who gets to decide which of those
priorities and which of those needs and
and which of those priorities are the
most critical uh and when we look at
some of the the data around the uh the
widening gap between the rich and the
poor uh the wealthy and the and the and
the
those who are in poverty uh you begin to
to think about some of the bottom-up
drivers of the policies and the
solutions that uh that we may all be
considering uh which in some cases when
you think about consumer behavior when
you think about the needs of of of the
broader broader uh population
can be as important as some of the
top-down ideas and and policies that
that we may consider
uh in fact uh uh i think one of the
things that we're seeing already and
will play themselves out in the in the
scenarios is uh
is a new gilded age
in in many respects with a
a widening gap between not just wealth
but also opportunity
education
skills and where this could be taking us
in some respects is that the attraction
of
liberal democratic systems are under
pressure
and even in liberal democratic nations
so
mountains
the first of our two scenarios
this is a relatively mountains it
deposits a relatively static uh world uh
the broad outlines of power in the world
remain
recognizable over the decades
change when it does happen tends to be
from the top by an elite that's really
uh needs to seek to preserve the the
status quo it's uh it does call to mind
the italian novelist giuseppe lampedusa
uh who wrote if we want things to stay
as they are things will have to change
and that's kind of what change looks
like in the in the in the mountains
world the core pattern that that you'll
recognize here is how advantage drives
more advantage so that gap that that
gilded age becomes even more exacerbated
influence
typically remains concentrated in the
hands of people who are already powerful
and already influential
and those few who do manage to rise
through that gap typically do so in this
mountains world they typically do so
through traditional
channels whether it be sports whether it
be business whether it be
popular culture
and that simply reinforces the the
prevailing ideology and the rigidity of
this mountain's world hampers collective
decision-making and it actually slows
down broad-based economic growth
at the same time however and somewhat
ironically with fewer power brokers
intent on protecting the status quo
established bilateral relationships
some progress is possible through what
we call secondary uh policies where
we're interests aligned an example might
be
authorities who might be uh
fearful of the kind of social stresses
that might arise in a large urban center
where resources are under stress
opportunities under stress transport is
under stress might find their interests
aligning with urban developers to
actually look at much more efficient
much more compact cities with with very
efficient more sustainable
infrastructure so you see some secondary
policies that emerge same thing actually
on the supply side and energy with that
very
static very
centralized kind of top-down
policy-making framework you might see
the possibility of things like
gas emerging much more quickly in an
accelerated fashion as the policy
framework required to allow for uh
development of of shale gas and other
resources is is pushed through same
thing with things like
climate carbon capture and storage
which does even today require a great
deal of concerted policy support
in energy terms the the slower pace of
economic development delays or relaxes
the
the pricing pressures and that means
that with a smaller number of
influential power brokers that enables a
more coherent and policy driven
investments
in infrastructure
in transport systems and as i said
earlier in cities governments are freer
to impose regulatory
restrictions on things like road
transports tail pipe emissions
efficiency standards fuel taxes and so
on
uh you see
countries like
china might be an example uh with its
political system able to to drive even
more aggressive policies around some of
the the pressures that they're seeing
both on the energy side and on the
climate side
so a big push into into gas is a
potential long-term alternative to coal
and i was just learning last night about
uh some of the projects that the china
has begun
in the nuclear power field as well
for those of you who like bar charts
just a kind of a a summary of what that
could look like in a mountains world
primary energy by source and and really
the summary here
uh is that uh with with a sluggish
economic growth uh and low demand uh as
a consequence
for energy
you see a very moderated sort of price
environment
which uh in some ways means good things
but in other ways that minimizes the
incentive to unlock new uh sources of
energy new innovations especially in the
renewable side
so you do see here a flattening of of
oil
in liquid fuels because as that
transport
infrastructure becomes less dependent on
on on liquid fuels it becomes more
electrified in compact cities uh where
uh where policy has uh created a much
more efficient infrastructure uh the uh
the the demand for oil tends to taper
off gas becomes the backbone
the uh the top-down policy frameworks
that allow for the unlocking of that gas
resource uh does uh accelerate the
production of of gas and that actually
has us as a beneficial effect on co2
you see
coal
more or less hold its own it actually
comes back again later in the century
but that's coal with with ccs
and you see a modest increase or
relatively modest increase in the in the
renewables and in the solar in this
mountains world
compare that then to to oceans
oceans is a much more volatile much more
bottoms-up world of empowered
populations driving structural reforms
much more economic activity much more
economic growth the participation in
leadership
tends to extend beyond the traditional
power base
there is an unrelenting distrust in
governments and in big business
and big business institutions which
means that a lot of innovation a lot of
uh of economic activity actually emerges
from other dimensions power
money
knowledge
all of those ebb and flow in a much more
spontaneous fashion than they do in uh
in mountains
and
the tina there is no alternative uh
world of uh where the u.s free-market
liberal democratic proposition the
liberal democratic model uh that world
is increasingly challenged by a terror
world there are real alternatives in
which company countries uh like china
and others are able to exert the kind of
soft power that was always uh
traditionally the domain of of the u.s
at least in recent history
and the challenge to traditional power
uh increases the number of those mini
lateral relationships that i talked
about a little bit earlier with sort of
this patchwork globalism that nourishes
competing ideologies and competing ideas
rules in in a notions world are very
difficult to enforce globally
even harder to agree on
and a growing social media
interconnectedness yes it does drive the
spread of information and the spread of
ideas but at the same time it also
creates a much more volatile world of
balkanized opinion where anybody
anywhere can find somebody to to support
the the view that they they may
intuitively hold
and reforms in this world um unleash new
productivity and growth but they also
serve to increase the appetite for more
of the same uh and in consumer terms
that means more cars it's more white
goods it means more air conditioning it
means more of those holidays on on on
airplanes
so as you will see this is a world in
which the co2 climate stresses become
even more acute
oceans in energy terms
it's a world of tight energy supply and
demand detention
and rising commodity prices and fast
emerging economies along with
the uh increasing population drive a
much higher demand to curve
and that rising price drives certainly
more efficiency technologies but it also
serves to unlock more expensive and more
ubiquitous sources of of energy uh again
uh like deep water arctic uh and uh and
it uh
uh had prob in many countries a
continuing dependency on coal
liquid fuel and coal continue to play a
leading role in this this ocean's world
and the energy mix
and they're only displaced somewhere
around the 2060 2070 time frame
by by
by solar when the impacts of climate
become so acute uh that an urgent and
abrupt transition needs to take place
in an ocean's world natural gas does
grow its share but it undershoots
expectations because of that lack of a
top-down supporting policy framework
and again
just to summarize
here we see at supply and demand tension
increasing uh that results in a higher
price environment and energy
it results also in a long liquids game
and finally a much later but much more
abrupt transition to solar
just to summarize those two things side
by side uh and to take a quick look back
at history um obviously in in both
oceans and mountains we can't rewrite
history um
contrary to some opinions but biomass in
uh before the the industrial revolution
transitioning to coal transitioning to
oil and now as we see what the future
could look like in these two scenarios
we see a mountains world much more
dependent on a natural gas backbone
and we see a ocean's world
more dependent longer on a coal oil mix
with a sudden transition to to solar out
in the back half of the century
to look at a couple of implications here
before uh before i ramp up so what does
all this potentially mean and again
there's a lot more in uh in the in the
book if you're if you're interested in
in uh
looking at it in in more detail but here
we see at least in the oceans context
and it's not all that different in the
mountains context that difference
between oecd
energy curves and non-oecd energy curves
and the main point that i want to make
here is that
a lot of the
of what drives the energy mix in the in
the uh developed world even though it's
a relatively flat demand curve what the
what drives that mix is the pressure
on the on the non-oecd the developing
world side so that price pressure that
demand pressure drives that lower oil
demand in in the mix on the developed
world uh and a more rapid uh take up of
uh of re renewables uh in uh in the in
the developed uh side of the
equation
here looking at an intra national look
mountains and oceans in the in the
context of just the united states
here ironically even though in mountains
there's a more sluggish growth you see a
slightly higher demand curve uh and
that's again a result of that influence
of the developing world and the and the
demand and the and the pricing tensions
there
this one is of particular interest uh
well to me as a former ford guy uh but
also in the in the context of shell i
think in many respects michelle might
be able to consider itself as much a
mobility company as it is an energy
company because a great deal of of the
energy that we that we produce
actually finds its way in some way shape
or form
into transport whether it be fuels
whether it be in lubricants whether it
actually even be in the plastics that go
into the the construction of vehicles so
we have a keen interest in what happens
in the transport world and uh and and
and
in ways that that we can
anticipate where that market is going
and here you see two very very different
pictures of how transport could develop
under these two different scenarios uh
and in the mountains uh world once again
uh because of that uh predominance of
top-down policy you see a much more
efficient
transport infrastructure one that
transitions to electricity much more
rapidly and eventually into hydrogen
in a significant and material fashion
because hydrogen will depend a great
deal on the policy frameworks that allow
for that collaboration uh with producers
and consumers and uh and
and
businesses
uh on the ocean side on the other hand
because of that sort of uh
palmell economic growth and uh and more
interest in the in the economic growth
and in transitioning to to different
models you see a longer dependence on on
liquid fuels
the link between energy and water um
again talking a lot about climate uh but
uh but the significance of the of the
the water uh
role in energy is uh is not to be
underestimated i have heard our own ceo
on occasions say
it's possible that water may be an even
more urgent
issue for a company like shell
even than than climate in some respects
because they're so interconnected
and uh and here you see the stresses
that are associated with uh with coal uh
in uh in the mountains but in oceans
that's that uh
transition to solar is going to come
with its own set of water stresses
and here
we start to get to the nub of what this
conference is about
the co2 contrast by by missions
point source and again
in in this in this context uh you see
mountains is not necessarily an
attractive world
but it does offer a quicker path to
lower emissions not attractive in the
sense of economic growth not attractive
necessarily even in the sense of of kind
of cultural dynamics but
it is a a quicker path to to lower
emissions on the co2 side
and that's a result of that slower
economic development
and
more government support for the
infrastructure required to reduce co2
like nuclear hydrogen
carbon capture and storage
and in compact cities
oceans gets close to zero by the end of
the century
but the
the time it takes to get to zero is is
much longer and the the curve is is much
greater uh and here is a curve that uh a
picture that will look familiar to you
and um
this is where the unpleasant punch line
comes in at least in terms of kind of
the current plausible scenarios the the
dotted line being of course the two
degree pathway uh oceans being the the
blue line at the top
and mountains being that line in the
middle the question then becomes
in my mind not just
what decisions we might make based on
what is plausible
against these scenarios but what are the
implausible things that we should be
looking at what are the
implausible things that should be
considered
that that could close this gap uh and
what are the implausible things that
should happen to to make this happen we
we do look at a range of what we know i
talked earlier about that plausibility
um there are uh is as i watched the the
twitter verse light up after the ipcc
report uh this uh this past weekend um
it's fascinating to see the range of
views that suggests that actually all of
this is impossible and we're toast and
there's absolutely nothing that we can
do about it at one end of the spectrum
and at the other end of the spectrum
there those who say well this is easy
stuff to do and we could get on with it
if just a few bad guys would get out of
the way probably neither is correct but
there are some breakthroughs some
different some changes some transitions
some discontinuous shifts that are
likely to be necessary in order to
tackle this this conundrum
uh and there are some sources of
optimism uh in in my view one of them
is emerges from from this chart which
looks at the
the pace of efficiency improvement over
the the last
50 years or so
so just a couple of examples here in
terms of the the energy required to make
a ton of steel which is enough to build
one car
24
gigajoules back in 1960 down to 13 giga
joules now no reason in the world why it
might not be down two to six in 2016.
you see a similar pattern for vehicle
miles traveled the energy required for a
household appliance and
even lighting your room
so major transitions are possible
and finally just a
few takeaways that i i offer for for
consideration uh and this these are my
words these aren't uh jeremy's the uh
although i don't think you disagree with
any of them the uh the dilemmas in in
this that emerge from the scenarios
they're long they're wide and they're
deep uh they're long term uh very very
long term um they
cross a number of different sectors a
number of different disciplines a number
of uh of of different cultures and
societies and they're very deep in the
sense of they get to the core not only
of how our business is run but how our
communities run how our governments run
uh and how perhaps in many respects we
as individuals lead our lives
they are existential not just political
so it's easy to kind of shift some of
these debates into
belief systems that that are based on on
political assumptions or or political
beliefs and in fact and again i think
mark said it very eloquently at the
beginning of the day these are really
about the existence of of of ourselves
and certainly future generations
intentional choices
require conscious trade-offs
the scenarios give us a tool to see some
of those choices and some of those uh
trade-offs uh and and what they tell us
very clearly and and what hopefully is
obvious to certainly everybody in this
room is there are no necessarily easy
answers but the intelligence required to
select amongst competing goods and bads
is is is necessary and it's not just a
matter of finding the right or the the
wrong answer it really is a matter of
trade-offs a plausible path to two
degrees will be very very hard uh but
again i'm an optimist uh it is not
impossible and and it's not impossible
mainly because there are some really
really bright people working on the
problem
but i should also
say that what we might be able to do
tomorrow should not condemn what we can
do today
and we need to avoid getting trapped in
that transition where nothing happens
because everything seems to be a bad
choice so for example
just to put in a a little bit of a plug
for some of the things that shell is
working on
we have for example a 40 dollar
per ton
cost of carbon that we apply to every
single project that we do inside the
company so we've already looked at the
scenarios and said yes this is something
that we're going to have to deal with
and that we have to deal with today and
one way to do that is to make sure that
even if the external market doesn't put
a cost on carbon that is appropriate
we'll put a cost of carbon on ourselves
and we'll run every project on all the
economics and all the technology of
those projects through that filter
the work that we're doing on carbon
capture and storage
i think one of the things that's
starting to emerge
from the ipcc report and others is that
ccs
is going to be absolutely essential to
any kind of solution that that we arrive
at
in the future
and
the we have a project in uh in canada uh
the significance of that is that um it's
about a 1.3 billion dollar project uh
the canadian uh uh state and um
uh federal government has contributed a
significant chunk of that
but about a third of that cost falls on
us there will be no return
to shell
on the the cost of that
carbon capture and storage project there
will be no return so this is an
investment in understanding how this
will work it's an investment in proving
out the concept it's an investment in
encouraging
other other governments and companies to
to
accelerate this the ccs technology and
the policies associated with it
and certainly some of the work that's
being done in biofuels we have a 12
billion dollar jv in in brazil around
sugar cane biofuels sugar cane of course
being
currently the most sustainable of the
the biofuels options uh out there
and then finally um we are bees as well
as chimps
uh and and here um as a uh as a
dilettante in the liberal arts uh i'm
i'm struck by uh some some uh of the the
works that i've read by e.o wilson who
talks about um
human evolution and and the fact that uh
the homo sapiens being sort of a eu
social uh species that uh that is is uh
activated by uh the survival of of the
species as much as it is by the survival
of the individual uh and i think if you
look back uh again as a liberal arts
dilettante if you look back over the
last four or five thousand years of
human history there is a case for
optimism where where
human society does find ways to tackle
those challenges to get out of that trap
transition
and to create for itself room to
maneuver
i hope some of this gives you some some
food for thought and some useful context
for the discussions that you're going to
be having for for the rest of the day um
it's again it's just such a privilege to
have the opportunity to share some of
this with you and i thank you very much
for your attention
you